la cifra finales se le otorgan al bloque
de Benjamin etanaju 64 escaños de los
120 disponibles en la quenet asegurando
una cómoda mayoría que les va a permitir
volver a gobernar Israel por tercera vez
algo inédito en la historia del Estado a
los 32 escaños de su partido licut se
suman los 14 de sionismo religiosos el
frente de extrema derecha antiárabe y
homófobo la alianza se completa con 11 y
7 asientos de los partidos Ultra
ortodoxos jazz y utj tras conocerse de
los resultados definitivos el Primer
Ministro saliente Yair lapiz le deseo
suerte a netaniaju y dijo que
garantizará una transición ordenada del
poder mientras que a nivel internacional
el primero en felicitar a nitañaju fue
otro líder derechista y afín el Primer
Ministro húngaro Víctor Urban que le
felicitó con el tradicional más el top
judío y aseguró que tiempos difíciles
requieren líderes fuertes a él se
sumaron figuras como el Primer Ministro
indio narendra Moody o el embajador
estadounidense en Israel Tom night que
llamó netaniaju a trabajar juntos para
mantener el lazo inquebrantable entre
ambos países el proceso de formación de
gobierno va a comenzar el 9 de noviembre
cuando el presidente Isaac jerson reciba
formalmente los resultados e inicie las
consultas partidarias una vez de que
reciba el mandato netanía Ju pretende
que las negociaciones con sus socios
para definir ministerios sean rápidas y
que un nuevo presidente del parlamento
pueda ser nombrado el 15 de noviembre
dando paso así a un nuevo ejecutivo que
se vislumbra como el más extremista de
derechas nacionalista y Ultra religioso
de Israel